animateur télé radio et web guillaume
Pley présente depuis plusieurs années un
certain nombre de programmes bienvenue
dans le QG
de lourdes accusations
de parole de Pascal le grand frère et JM
[Musique]
les longs de l'animateur l'une de ses
anciennes stagiaires l'accuse même
d'attouchement un jour il me caresse la
cuisse sans mon consentement de nombreux
témoignages accablent l'animateur
guillaume Pley d'anciens collaborateurs
témoignent ce soir dans TPMP
merci d'être avec nous il est 20h52 on
est en direct et c'est vrai que cette
affaire fait énormément parler ce qui le
connaissent ou ceux qui ne connaissent
pas tout le monde ne parle que de ça en
ce moment guillaume Pley donc
l'animateur et c'est vrai que pas mal de
témoignages lacables on a reçu le
témoignage d'une ancienne collaboratrice
de guillaume Pley manipulation
exploitation humiliation elle raconte
les coulisses et les crins personnages
très problématiques après bien sûr c'est
leur vision voilà on dit à chaque fois
il faut prendre ça bien sûr aux
conditionnel elle explique que ça se
passait bien au début mais que
rapidement elle commence à comprendre
que guillaume Pley opère en douceur en
manipulation pour finalement exploiter
ses équipes voilà est-ce que voilà
écoutez après on va en parler
et puis quand le projet a vraiment
commencé à venir le jour c'est là qu'on
a vu la vraie son vrai visage ça
m'étonne entre guillemets c'est de
d'installer vraiment confiance avec ses
équipes
pour pousser les exploiter un petit peu
sans forcément quoi qui sont CFF
de ces équipes pour les surcharger
travail et les exploiter les faire
travailler beaucoup en disant tu es
jeune il faut que tu bosses c'est comme
ça dans le milieu c'est ça c'est comme
ça sinon ça ira jamais
alors Gilles là ce qu'on entend alors
c'est Camille le prénom a été changé on
a Yannick Vinel qui est avec nous
animateur et producteur radio qui a
commencé à travailler avec guillaume
Pley en 2013 tu vas nous raconter tout
ça merci en tout cas d'être moins
Yannick Gilles alors les langues se
délicient effectivement sur guillaume
Pley je dirais qu'il y a deux volets le
premier volet c'est vraiment au
quotidien le travail qui semble pour
toutes les équipes pour tous les gens
qui travaillent avec lui notamment les
jeunes très difficiles il est
irrespectueux il est manipulateur
parfois même il vole des idées c'est ce
que dit Pascal le grand frère que lui a
soumis l'idée du nom QG et hop il lui a
pris le nom il lui avait promis de
l'inviter il ne l'a jamais invité donc
il y a ça et puis il y a aussi des les
premiers témoignages faut utiliser le
conditionnel bien entendu oui oui les
premiers témoignages qui évidemment j'ai
même la réaction de guillaume Pley si
vous voulez qui a fait un communiqué on
donnera tout à l'heure comme ça ça
équilibré voilà les premiers témoignages
dont celle d'une ancienne stagiaire qui
décrivent ce qui s'apparente dans ses
propos à elle a dû harcèlement sexuel
voilà donc il le volet de guillaume Pley
qui se révèle aujourd'hui un personnage
que personnellement moi j'ai côtoyé ici
la saison 2016 et dont on ne
présupposait pas que tout ça sortirait
très récemment après voilà après alors
ça a démarré aussi avec cette affaire de
Pascal le grand frère il adore et
Jean-Marc Michelin je les adore les deux
qui donnaient une interview youtubeur
Darko ils ont répondu une question
simple quel personnalité de la télé et
alors c'était la question est un vrai
con alors la réponse est claire il donne
des exemples écoutez
longtemps en fait moi j'étais le tampon
entre lui et les équipes tu vois ok ça
se passait très très mal avec les
équipes en vrai tu vois c'est devenu un
secret pour personne en fait mais oui
personne
moi il me l'a mis à l'envers elle a fait
il m'a fait un truc mais incroyable je
sais que c'est pas possible non en gros
en gros tu vois j'ai dû me rendre à un
enterrement le jeudi tu vois le vendredi
on a une émission de télé donc juste le
lendemain je lui dis écoute le lendemain
je peux pas être là parce que ben j'ai
pas la tête à ça tu vois c'est premier
d'essai assez proche et le lundi je
retourne à la radio et il me dit ben tu
vas être écarté l'émission de télé pour
ne pas être venu après l'enterrement et
du coup j'ai fait pardon j'essaierai la
main j'ai dit on a pas le sens c'est on
a pas les mêmes valeurs de la vie merci
au revoir de moi après je dois quitter
merci au revoir
alors c'est vrai que ça ça et Pascal a
rajouté vous avez dit qu'il y avait volé
le nom de son émission regardez
parce que moi je vais te dire la vérité
quand tu as appelé ta boîte le QG qui
t'a donné l'idée
parce que je voudrais créer un truc
YouTube qu'est-ce que tu en penses ça
peut cartonner je dois le nom de cherche
un nom c'est quoi je dis moi j'ai appelé
ma société le QG et tu vois c'est pas
mal ouais j'ai
honte et il devait m'inviter à plusieurs
reprises ouais je t'inviterai il m'a
jamais invité déjà donc parle pas pour
rien et puis la caroté aussi mon
collègue là viens parce que tu as invité
du monde là truc qui font des sports de
combat bien je te dis viens
[Musique]
alors après c'est vrai que c'est un
déferlement notamment sur les réseaux il
y a émis Aymeric Bonnery aussi que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'est lâché chez
Jordan Deluxe qu'il a défoncé aussi et
on a Yannick qui était avec nous toi tu
as commencé à travailler avec guillaume
Pley en 2013 tu avais 18 ans et tu étais
très content d'obtenir un stage donc
c'était lui que c'est lui qui t'a pris
en stage sur NRJ exactement c'est ma
première expérience c'est lui qui a été
voir c'est lui c'est JM que j'ai
rencontré
exactement que j'ai rencontré pour le
stage donc du coup bah ça c'est fait
j'ai fait j'ai commencé ce stage au
début ça se passait bien il parlait pas
trop en tout cas il me parlait pas trop
donc c'était il y a 10 ans et donc
j'étais au standard pour que les gens
comprennent donc en général quand on est
stagiaire c'est comme ça qu'on commence
en radio et c'est vrai que ben j'ai j'ai
foiré une séquence parce que l'auditeur
était pas bon et cetera mais j'apprenais
c'était ma première expérience et du
coup Guillaume me dit trop rien et le
lendemain il me convoque on était dans
un open space faut s'imaginer qu'à
l'énergie c'est un open space ou on
travaillait tous au quatrième étage il y
avait l'équipe de Guillaume mais il y
avait d'autres services donc on était
devant plein de gens et il me dit
Yannick lève-toi donc là je me lève et
tout et il me dit en gros
tu as foiré la séquence etc donc
évidemment je m'excuse je me dis
excuse-moi je suis désolé et tout et là
il commence à se Charner sur moi en
disant mais regarde toi comme tu es
personne voudra de toi plus tard même
des petites radios locales ne voudront
pas de toi il commençait à rigoler de
moi à
que mon physique personne ne voudra
travailler de moi parce qu'avant toi tu
es beau gosse non mais avant j'étais
obèse je faisais j'ai perdu 60 65 kg
donc faut imaginer je faisais que 140 kg
j'étais pas du tout le Yannick de
maintenant non mais quand même et c'est
beau quand même hein
mais du coup je commence donc en face de
lui j'ai 18 ans je pleurais il
continuait ils continuaient au bout d'un
moment il me dit bon allez on passe à
autre chose du coup moi je me suis rassi
j'ai continué mon stage et je voulais
arrêter c'était ma première expérience
mais je me suis dit ce monde des médias
c'est un monde affreux je vais pas avoir
les épaules etc et heureusement qu'après
j'ai eu d'autres expériences je suis
parti sur Virgin Radio à l'époque avec
Enora la chance de produire l'émission
exactement et alors tu vois je vais te
poser une question et toi tu as
travaillé avec moi d'ailleurs moi il
m'arrive aussi et je le dis je le mange
franchement je m'en cache pas ici de
dire voilà c'est de la merde truc les
gars ou déconner qu'est-ce qui me
différencie d'un guillaume Pley tu
pourrais dire aussi Cyril bah c'est vrai
Cyril il est venu me voir
merde truc c'est vrai je le dis la bosse
dit la vérité j'ai dit tu le sais voilà
donc qu'est-ce qui fait que lui il est
border et pas moi
si déjà la première chose c'est la
fidélité guillaume Pley il a jamais
gardé ses collaborateurs moi je vais
dire mais moi il me l'a fait à l'envers
parce que voilà parce qu'ils étaient
toujours à bout vous là toutes les
personnes il y en a plein de claques qui
sont là depuis 5 ans depuis 10 ans vos
collaborateurs en production aussi donc
il reste donc mine de rien la fidélité
ça veut dire quand même quelque chose si
vraiment on est à bout d'un moment on
part et la deuxième chose moi Guillaume
ça fait 15 ans que je connais c'est que
je n'ai pas entendu et je connais
peut-être 30 personnes qui travaillent
avec lui il y a un consensus dans le
métier pour dire que c'est un femme de
travailler avec lui que ce soit les
patrons les stagiaires les
collaborateurs donc au bout d'un moment
moi je suis contre le lynchage quand il
y a un témoignage parce que vous faites
attention non pour moi voilà moi aussi
je l'ai appelé je l'ai insulté voilà
mais moi aussi
on parle aussi de de de d'une équipe
composée que de stagiaires pour garder
tout l'argent pour soi de de
comportement très compliqué vous savez
de quoi on m'accusait aussi pour vous
dire ouais je vous dis moi par exemple
voilà quand je lance conviction par
exemple quand j'ai lancé quand j'ai
lancé je sais pas moi Camille à l'époque
c'est moi qui avait trouvé le nom de
l'émission et on pense à Camille c'est
moi qui avait trouvé le truc donc c'est
ça donc je fais un truc c'est vrai que
je dis on partage les droits d'auteur et
et les mecs qui m'ont dit que tu
partages des droits d'auteur parce que
tu n'écris pas sur la mission c'est moi
qui trouvait le concept c'est moi qui
fait l'émission
n'est pas l'antenne donc pour vous dire
ouais ou pas mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait
que voilà
différence aussi par rapport à ce que
vous venez de raconter je mets pas du
tout en doute votre histoire c'est que
vous quand vous nous engueulez et y
compris quand vous engueulez tous
ensemble dans la loge et que les autres
sont témoins de l'engueulade vous là
vous ne venez nous raconter une
humiliation sur votre personne et pas
sur votre travail à jamais vous nous
dites
tu n'étais pas trop gros
merci entre nous et c'est un truc entre
nous et c'est une histoire d'amitié
entre vous et c'est quelque chose qui
Benjamin en souffrait il vous l'aurez
dit vous Aurier là en l'occurrence c'est
un garçon qui semblait être vulnérable à
18 ans et on va appuyer sur le rend
malheureux ce qui est assez on va dire
le mot étrange c'est que Guillaume n'a
jamais dit tu es un sale gros etc il me
l'a pas dit directement mais gagnant
mais dans ce que j'ai compris dans ce
que j'ai ressenti c'était clairement le
message que il voulait me en fait il
voulait me faire mal il voulait pas me
dire que j'étais pas bon il voulait me
faire mal sauf que la vraie différence
avec avec Siri c'est que là dans ce
cas-là c'est un cas qu'on rencontre
souvent dans ce métier c'est que ils
sont ils sont forts avec les faibles et
puis dès qu'il y a un mec qui est au
niveau au-dessus Cyril si par là la même
façon un petit qui a un très grand il y
a pas de différence et dans ce cas-là et
c'est vrai que apparemment c'est que
quand c'est les mecs de son niveau ou
au-dessus comme ça que en tout cas moi
de ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'à mon époque
donc il y avait 10 ans en arrière et
Guillaume était son équipe on était
pratiquement autant de stagiaire que de
salariés après moi voilà alors tiens il
y a mon frérot Aymeric que j'adore moi
tu sais que je l'aime vraiment je
l'adore ce mec c'est un mec que je kiffe
raconte le coup qui lui a fait avec sa
fille
c'est quoi cette histoire tu as eu un
coup toi
et il m'a fait un truc avec ma fille non
le jour où elle voulait assister à son
émission parce qu'il y avait un déserté
de ces artistes préférés ouais mais il
l'a fait rentrer il a dit qu'il avait
plus de place après moi j'ai il pouvait
plus rentrer avec la sécu moi j'ai
appelé un autre gars qui était sur NRJ à
l'époque j'ai appelé Laurent Thibault
que tu connais très bien monsieur et
Guillaume après elle l'a fait rentrer à
faire rentrer pour le coup elle est
rentrée elle a vu l'émission pour le
coup c'est avec Nayel des One Direction
non mais c'est ça le paradoxe c'est que
Guillaume si on écoute ses fans ces
auditeurs etc tout le monde j'entendais
autour de moi des gens qui étaient pas
dans le milieu oh là là qu'est-ce que
guillaume Pley c'est un mec gentil il a
l'air vraiment adorable et ici quand il
était là avec nous on a rien vu
mais avec ces petites équipes en tout
cas moi je veux dire les chéris on a
arrêté parce que sur les équipes je
commençais à voir des personnes dans mes
équipes qui se plaignaient et qui me
disaient qu'il y avait de gros problèmes
avec lui et c'est pour ça aussi
d'ailleurs que j'ai décidé aussi
d'arrêter l'émission aussi voilà il y
avait des problèmes au sein de la
production avec des gens qui se
plaignaient qui disaient que c'était
très compliqué et que voilà il y avait
voilà je le dis moi moi il m'arrive
voilà je lis qu'Alexandre truc et tout
mais on s'entend très très bien ça donc
c'est vrai que c'est plus des vannes des
rigolotes tout ça mais il paraît que là
c'était assez violent et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai une émission
à l'envers parce que effectivement vous
avez dit ça tout à l'heure c'est pas de
ça donc il s'agit c'est encore autre
chose à faire c'est nous qui l'avons
lancé sur la télé mais puis derrière
c'est vrai qu'il parlait mal de nous et
cetera de toute façon je me suis pas je
l'ai déjà appelé la prière c'est bon
pour moi c'est réglé voilà après les
autres font ce qu'ils veulent mais moi
c'est c'est une affaire qui est qui est
pratiquement classique
parce que j'ai j'ai encore le le
témoignage d'autres d'autres vocaux de
ces témoignages d'une ancienne
collaboratrice elle va plus loin
puisqu'elle parle comme beaucoup
d'humiliation auquel elle aurait assisté
personnel il y a vraiment une espèce
d'humiliation auquel j'ai assisté
[Musique]
physique et tout ça quoi il y a ce truc
de on est tellement sous pression et un
truc un peu de mon armement peur de ce
qu'il m'a dit et de lui que bah on
dirait un truc quoi alors
donc Yannick c'est vrai que vous allez
travailler avec lui moi je vous dis le
truc que j'ai et je vous dis voilà moi
je sais qu'il y a plein de trucs aussi
voilà de documentaire qui se prépare sur
moi tout le monde peut dire anonymement
tout et n'importe quoi donc c'est ça le
truc aussi qui me dérange et vous avez
vu que je le défends pas puisque le gars
voilà je l'aime pas particulièrement
Yannick c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
et c'est pour ça en fait que j'ai pour
être très honnête hésité à témoigner
parce que je sais que ça va porter plus
de problèmes qu'autre chose au bout d'un
moment je me suis dit ça fait 10 ans
maintenant voilà je suis producteur le
matin donc je gère des équipes comme lui
il était il était animateur producteur
et évidemment qu'on peut trouver un
stagiaire ou un collaborateur qui dit
des fois on a des excès de colère on les
a tous parce que dans n'importe quel
boulot on a des excès de colère et ça je
l'aurais compris mais c'était sa façon
de te tourner le truc de te rentrer dans
ton cerveau moi je finisse donc
l'émission je crois qu'elle finissait à
2h du matin à l'époque et moi des fois
je restais au bureau jusqu'à 4h du matin
j'avais mon école le lendemain à 8h et
je disais Guillaume des fois c'est pas
possible quand on travaille le dimanche
on travaille tous les jours je
l'acceptais et je regrette pas et
franchement en vrai je vais vous dire la
vérité Cyril je vais j'ai envie quand
même de lui dire entre guillemets merci
parce qu'il m'a donné en vrai la
première opportunité de faire de la rage
c'est ça voilà et ça moi jamais ce sera
sur les personnes qui m'ont nourris et
ça c'est la vérité mais par contre il y
a des méthodes qui ne sont pas ok alors
elle dit que pour elle c'est très clair
tout le monde savait et les équipes en
parler entre eux ils se soutenaient
écoutez
[Musique]
qui veut parler depuis tout à l'heure
oui non parce qu'en fait je moi j'en ai
entendu parler parce que j'étais partie
du groupe énergie pendant un certain
temps et effectivement il y avait quand
même enfin c'était pas des espèces de on
va dire de témoignage comme ça isolés il
y avait quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
rumeurs de bruissement sur ce genre de
effectivement de comportement
d'humiliation et c'est vrai que la
différence entre quand on fait partie de
ce métier là effectivement qu'on peut
croiser des personnages qui sont
autoritaires qui sont parfois exigeants
et c'est bien normal de l'être quand on
est en direct tous les jours comme vous
Cyril non mais parce qu'on est obligé de
travailler avec des gens avant de
travailler avec moi forcément vous avez
entendu des choses sur moi
je serais pas venu je crois sinon
entendu des trucs d'humiliation en fait
la différence c'est le vice voilà on
sent qu'il y a du vice et c'est ce qui
se disait en tout cas c'est ce qu'il dit
moi je l'ai pas vécu directement mais au
sein du groupe
sa jasait quand même pas mal et ça se
disait quand même pas mal
vous dites il y a des documentaires qui
se préparent sur moi parce que vous vous
êtes au cœur de l'actu que vous marchez
que les gens sont énervés sont jaloux
Guillaume là il a pu non plus sous le
feu des projecteurs donc pourquoi ça
sort maintenant de gens qui les connais
pas encore une fois voilà je veux pas
l'accuser mais il y a deux choses qui
sont symptomatiques c'est un le gros
Turner dans ses équipes il y a très peu
de collaborateurs qui sont restés avec
lui et puis ils sont turn overling il a
tout le temps changé d'employeur il
était sur NRJ en Belgique après il est
parti en France sur gum radio il est
retournait energy ensuite il allait
assez vite ensuite il allait sur M6 donc
en général quand quelqu'un change tout
le temps comme ça d'employeur comme ça
c'est aussi symptomatique de
comportement problématique même avec la
direction donc ça c'est une question qui
se pose Yannick j'aimerais que te poser
une question est-ce qu'il y a une
personne qui devait venir ce soir
témoigner aussi et elle s'est désistée
elle a dit la peur est fort il s'agit
d'une personne qui possède des armes
chez lui et le fait largement savoir il
est dangereux et tyrannique est-ce que
tu es au courant de ça
honnêtement je suis au courant de rien
là-dessus je ne sais pas en tout cas moi
j'ai rien vu je
ce que je peux juste dire c'est que
moi avec tous les stagiaires parce qu'on
était un petit groupe on parlait même
des salariés qui étaient à l'époque avec
Guillaume nous on en parlait à chaque
fois entre nous on disait ouais c'est
pas possible de se laisser marcher comme
ça on en parlait à JM JM donc Jean-Marc
michelian voilà qui faisait le tampon
entre Guillaume et les équipes qui
connaissaient cette situation et qui en
même temps était lui aussi je lui en
veux pas de pas avoir pris de décision
parce que dans cette situation je sais
même pas comment personnellement
j'aurais réagi mais le seul truc c'est
que c'était bien rodé parce que moi
j'étais en stage sur la boîte de
production de guillaume Pley et pas
stagiaire chez NRJ et en fait quand ça
se passait comme c'était une émission
tard le soir la direction d'énergie les
salariés étaient pas forcément là donc
du coup ça se ça se ressentait on
entendait dire mais en vrai est-ce que
la direction d'énergie est au courant je
pense pas en vrai je pense pas ou sinon
enfin j'espère qu'ils auraient pris des
des sanctions envers l'animateur même si
ils devaient fonctionner je pense en
audience à l'époque oui la grande
différence entre vous et lui c'est que
lui on retrouve de manière constante un
climat pesant un climat sur les équipes
avec moi je suis pas beaucoup là
climat de pression peut-être de
harcèlement moral mais ça c'est une
définition juridique mais en tout cas de
mauvais comportement permanent avec les
équipes qui n'en peuvent plus etc ici
vous pouvez avoir des éclats des
emportements mais il y a pas du tout un
climat pesant il y a une très bonne
ambiance et ça c'est la grande
différence et lui on retrouve ça à tous
les niveaux souvenons-nous quand même
qu'il est aussi célèbre pour en 2013
avoir fait la fameuse vidéo comment
embrasser une inconnue en 10 secondes
vous vous souvenez de ça qui avait
suscité une polémique il y avait pas eu
de plaintes mais quand même aujourd'hui
ça hier ça ne passait pas mais
aujourd'hui ce serait condamné parce que
c'était violent c'était allé à la
rencontre d'inconnu et presque les
forcer à être embrassés voilà donc c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours fait régner une
sorte de climat pesant qui aujourd'hui
éclate au grand jour moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que de toutes les
personnes qu'on travaille avec Guillaume
que je connaisse que je connais
honnêtement il y en a pas une qui me
dise du bien alors il y a Aymeric bon en
direct salut Aymeric merci d'être là
Aymeric qui a travaillé avec lui oui
Aymeric je voulais intervenir moi je
fais pas polémiquer davantage mais je
pense que ça va sortir au fur et à
mesure parce que c'est c'est une belle
enflure on va pas tirer sur l'ambulance
alors
on a dit
moi on est deux personnages
[Musique]
mais en fait au quotidien lui ce qu'il
fait c'est que c'est que des magouilles
c'est à dire qu'il te fait disjoncter
qui fait péter les plombs et puis
tu es toujours habile c'est toujours
habile c'est c'est un mec qui te serre
la main si tu veux tu vois il te la
broie devant ta direction il va
t'appeler il va te dire voilà je sais
que tu récupères le studio dans 5
minutes je vais mettre une boule plante
dans ton studio et en fait tu lui dis
non c'est pas possible il y a les
équipes c'est pas en plus c'est pas moi
qui vais nettoyer tu vois c'est mais
c'est mes petits gars je lui dis non
c'est pas possible et lui en fait c'est
ça au quotidien tu arrives tu retrouves
une gousse dans la poubelle sur NRJ
comment je suis arrivé sur NRJ en fait
ce mec là moi j'avais une petite
émission radio je payais de ma poche
pour la faire
il a pris ma coanimatrice il a créé en
fait un où il y avait un espèce de
tournoi et au bout du tournoi il devait
y avoir la future animatrice pour
l'émission de l'année prochaine
et ben il a rien trouvé de mieux que
l'humilier et cette animatrice elle
perdra si elle veut mais il a humilié en
direct tout ça pour me faire du mal à
moi et donc lui c'était un garçon qui
était pas très courageux et il s'en
prenait beaucoup beaucoup Onana et et
c'est horrible pour ça moi j'ai récupéré
un paquet de stagiaires qui pourront
témoigner qui était au bout du rouleau
qui était en pleurs qui arrivait pas à
s'épanouir et je l'ai récupéré à la
petite cuillère j'ai des dizaines de
messages ou des gens me disent merci
merci parce que à un moment donné tu tu
m'as donné une lueur d'espoir dans NRJ
mais parce que j'étais au contact quoi
mais il faisait en fait souffrir les
gens c'était de la souffrance mais de la
souffrance morale et parfois bah c'est
pire que que que que voilà exactement
si tu veux venir nous voir tu es le
bienvenu je te fais de gros bisous mon
frérot je t'aime fort je t'embrasse mon
chéri je t'embrasse fort